ray is on Facebook why term life
insurance instead of whole life life
insurance what's the difference
term life insurance is just insurance
that's all it is it's like your car
insurance that's all you get you don't
get any money unless you die and so you
don't ever get any money it goes to your
beneficiary right the only way it pays
off is when you die don't weigh your car
insurance pays off you don't make money
on your car insurance your homeowners
insurance
that's pure insurance that's all it does
it doesn't have any gimmicks or bells or
whistles that has an investment built
into it or you can buy cash value life
insurance which includes whole life or
universal life or variable life now
here's the typical numbers okay the
typical numbers are for five dollars you
can buy as much term life insurance on a
20-year level term as you can for a
hundred dollars buying cash value life
insurance per month so why would you pay
ninety five dollars more per month
because it builds up inside of it a
savings account called cash value it
builds up a savings plan so that then
later on if you close the policy they
will write you a check and give you your
savings back so you have you buy
insurance in a sense for five dollars
and you invest ninety five dollars out
of every $100 per month so why is that
bad what's bad for a multitude of
reasons number one the rate of return on
the typical whole life policy is around
one percent about like your stupid
savings account at the bank and no one
builds wealth at one percent on a
universal life after all the fees now
they quote you a higher rate but after
all the fees your net is around four
point seven percent these are all
documented numbers and on a variable
which has mutual funds in it by the time
the mutual funds get through the
all the ways of the insurance company
what should have been a 10 or 12 percent
rate of return lends up looking like
about a 6% rate of return so they hit
you heavy with the fees if you want your
money out of your quote savings account
out of your quote investment there's
only two ways to get it one is cancel
your policy and lose your insurance or
two is borrow it no I meant you're gonna
borrow your own money and pay them
interest to borrow money you put into an
investment well that's stupid but people
do it all the time and people that sell
this crap act like that's tax-free
return it's not tax free it's borrowed
money and you're paying in interest to a
more to an insurance company that would
get your own stinking money but here's
the worst thing let's say you buy like a
couple hundred thousand dollar policy
and you pay in two and you pay in two
and you pay in two and you pay in two
and finally it gets past all these fees
and there's a hundred thousand dollars
in there and you die your cash value is
a hundred thousand your face value is
two hundred thousand you die you know
what they pay two hundred thousand they
pay the face amount what happened to
your hundred thousand that you paid
ninety five dollars per hundred dollars
a month extra to build up well we don't
know apparently they keep it so you have
a savings account with a lousy rate of
return that when you die they keep your
savings that's whole life life insurance
it is one of the worst financial
products in the world it is the payday
lender of the middle class without a
doubt and the people that sell this
stuff should be ashamed of themselves
it's absolutely horrendous it's just
it's sad and you know here's what's
really sad they are really good at
selling it well term insurance you know
your term insured is gonna run out about
the time you die and your family is just
gonna be left with nothing and you know
do you rent your house or do you buy
your house
you know you're buying your policy we're
not buying your policy with whole life
if you quit paying it you know what
they'll cancel it you could paying your
term insurance they'll cancel it you
know you don't build up equity in this
you are buying equity after they picked
your pocket some of it builds equity
called cash value but you still lose it
all when you die and so it's absolutely
ludicrous the whole sales process and
you know here's the thing it's 20 times
more expensive for the same amount of of
life insurance and guess what the agent
gets paid their commission on they get
paid their commission on premium so the
edging gets paid on a hundred bucks
rather than five bucks for the same
amount of life insurance and so what
ends up happening is people buy this
crap and they don't buy enough life
insurance to take care of their family
and then they die with these stupid but
tiny little whole life policies that are
1/10 of what they ought to be so you
ought to have about 10 to 12 times your
income on you
meaning if you make $50,000 a year you
ought to have five hundred six hundred
thousand dollars in life insurance on
you you die your spouse takes that and
invest it if they make eight or ten
percent then they're creating $50,000 a
year and you've been replaced that that
lump sum investment will pay your family
what you used to earn before you died
and it's that simple and you know it
just doesn't cost anything term life
insurance is very very inexpensive to
get the proper amount and this is why I
have endorsed all indoor endorsed term
life insurance from the very first day I
turned on this microphone 25 years ago
and why have endorsed Sander insurance
to get your term life insurance because
they shop and get you the best possible
price
they're great folks they do a great job
of taking care of the customer I
personally buy my insurance of xander
but whether you buy it there or not
never by cash value insurance it's
absolutely an antiquated crappy product
and it's all about them making money
it's nothing about you making money
that's what I mean by being the payday
lender or the middle class it's just
horrendous so I hope that helps you're a
go to Xandar insurance com get you a
quick easy quote on that term and that's
what you ought to do what I do and it's
what I've done virtually my whole life
yeah there you go
this is the Dave Ramsey show